i can't stand when i go to a concert and
they sing along i hate it then you don't
want to go to a concert with me you sing
during the concert i was singing so loud
during a paul mccartney concert
i would jennifer aniston turned around
to see who was making all that noise
i was like oh no and i hate when the guy
is standing on stage the lead singer and
he takes his microphone and he points it
at the audience
i didn't come to hear the audience i
came to hear you
he wanted us to sing
uh marianne from brooklyn go ahead
what's up i love you helen
you know what i'm thinking how mick
jagger was talking to you and he said
how can you not stand so how can you not
sing at a concert robin i was at paul
mccartney and i was singing i sat in
front of
david let me set you straight for a
second
it is rude i went to the billy joel
concert
and i'm standing there
and why am i standing i got to see
i'm standing because every [ __ ] has
to stand up don't you get that vibe in
you
don't forget that listen to me what i do
is it's a bunch of people trying to
prove they know the words to the song
they want to show off to whoever they're
with something else it's a community
experience you could play the record at
home to yourself when you go to a
concert it's the audience and
the performer are you so narcissistic
that you believe that i'm at the concert
to hear you sing instead of billy joel
come on how can billy joel look at an
audience and see everyone sitting there
like a mummy how could that be you want
to know something one time when i was
watching billy joel i caught myself
trying to sing along and all of a sudden
i said oh i'm doing what i don't like
i'm being rude and what i did was i
mowed the words i didn't actually
sing
well that wouldn't help billy either
because he doesn't know why your mouth
is moving
i don't know man
sing us a song can you imagine you hear
this behind your
[Music]
all right